[Musique]
tu es avec nous pour en parler vincent
chauvet maire modem d'autun en
saône-et-loire julien odoul porte parole
du rassemblement national et enfin julie
garnier oratrice de la france insoumise
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
évidemment beaucoup de de débat dans la
société française aujourd'hui dans les
cafés puisque on en profite encore un
petit peu beaucoup de réactions
politiques
aussi après la pression mise par
emmanuel macron sur les rares
réfractaires à la vaccination je vous
propose tout d'abord d'écouter marine le
pen la patronne du rassemblement
national recul grave des libertés
individuelles des constructions de
l'état liquidation de notre système de
protection sociale
la feuille de route de macron est clair
c'est encore les français qui paieront
l'imprévoyance et l'incompétence de nos
dirigeants
pour nous c'est non alain julien odoul
n'y passe sanitaires ni vaccination
obligatoire d'aidés soignants pour vous
rassemblement national pour nous racines
nationales un principe devait présider
un principe essentiel c'était le
principe de liberté marine le pen depuis
le mois de décembre dernier avait
demandé que la liberté soit respectée
liberté pour tous les français qui le
souhaitaient de se faire vacciner
et force est de constater qu'au début de
la campagne de vaccination les français
que nos compatriotes qui souhaitaient
trouver une dose de vaccin ne le
pouvaient pas pour les problèmes
évidemment que nous avons rencontré
problèmes logistiques les carences
problème au niveau européen et puis
liberté pour tous les autres pour les
français qui avaient des doutes et en
démocratie
les doutes sont légitimes le président
de la république d'alors l'avait bien
dit au mois de décembre
on n'avait pas assez de recul sur ce
vaccin donc un bond de français n'était
pas hostile à la vaccination vous savez
on est le pays pasteur bombe de france
est donc ne sont pas hostiles
viscéralement et spontanément à la
vaccination mais souhaitait attendre
souhaitez avoir plus d'information plus
de pédagogie et force est de constater
que le gouvernement a échoué dans ce
domaine là et le gouvernement depuis
donc ces six derniers mois a échoué pour
convaincre les français a échoué
il semble que cette campagne de
vaccination soit un succès et comme il a
échoué
donc dans ce pouvoir de conviction comme
le lien de confiance avec les français
n'a pas été établie aujourd'hui il
emploie la manière forte
aujourd'hui on a de la brutalité parce
que les annonces du président de la
république était d'une brutalité inouïe
hier instauré clairement deux catégories
de citoyens faire en sorte que les
français n'ont vacciné soient considérés
comme des sous citoyens avec moins de
droits avec moins de liberté est tout
simplement revenir sur des libertés
individuelles fondamentales liberté
d'aller et venir liberté d'entreprendre
liberté de voyager tout cela est
extrêmement grave et aujourd'hui on voit
bien que le gouvernement masquer ses
échecs masquer ses insuffisances match
aussi tout ce qu'il n'a pas fait la
recherche sur le traitement
les contrôles aux frontières le
renforcement des capacités et laterrière
les américains par des rv à on va
évidemment voir ces mesures pardonnez
moi de vous ma fait en détail puisque
vous êtes trois enfants on va aller plus
loin dans ce débat vincent chauvet comme
le dit julien houde il aurait fallu
davantage convaincre et peut-être un
petit peu moins fort c'est parce que
vous en conviendrez c'est ce qui se
passe un petit peu les non vaccinés
en gros pas d'autre choix que plus ou
moins de rester chez eux ou de
pique-niqué dans un parc vide alors
peut-être en tout cas au début la
campagne de vaccination s'est bien
déroulé il y avait même plus de demande
que de vaccins ces derniers mois on
avait réussi à équilibrer la demande et
la livraison de vaccins et puis on se
rend compte finalement depuis quelques
semaines que à la fois là le rythme de
la vaccination stagne et en même temps
qu'on reçoit davantage de vaccins et
troisième élément que ce variant delta
qui est beaucoup plus contagieux se
répand extrêmement vite et qui
aujourd'hui représentent la majorité des
contaminations
donc effectivement il faut accélérer la
vaccination moi j'étais tout à l'heure
dans le centre municipal de vaccination
à autun et il ya beaucoup de monde qui
est venu s'inscrire parce qu'ils veulent
voyager parce que ils veulent
effectivement ils sont convaincus ils
attendaient à une partie qui étaient
attentistes et puis qui se dit
maintenant c'est le moment
donc pas forcément des gens qui étaient
contrats des personnels soignants mais
aussi des gens qui voulaient prendre le
train voyage et qui se disent bon bah
maintenant pour pour avoir cessé liberté
je me vaccine effectivement c'est le
pass and i ter la vaccination c'est
contraire à l'esprit général des
libertés publiques mais n'oublions pas
que nous sommes dans un état d'urgence
sanitaire il ya moins d'un an
à moins d'un an et demi et le présent de
la public disait nous sommes en guerre
nous sommes toujours dans une situation
sanitaire tout de même
ils ne devaient pas nécessairement être
prolongé une nouvelle fois et c'est
pourtant le cas ce qu'on ne traite pas
les les français comme des enfants julie
garnier clairement alors c'est vrai
qu'on est français ont semble-t-il
appris leur leçon à 800000 vaccination
aujourd'hui 1
je crois que le gouvernement est
toujours en guerre mais c'est surtout il
hier il a fait une déclaration de guerre
sociale parce que dans les trois grandes
mesures on va dire qu'il ya qui ont été
annoncés hier à savoir le past and i
terme il ya aussi la réforme retraites
chômage est aussi l'absence de mesures
envers les profiteurs de guerre
on voit bien acquis emmanuel macron
demande des comptes en premier sur le
vaccin pour revenir sur le passé ni
terre bien évidemment la première le
premier de ces réflexes comme à chaque
fois c'est de revenir sur les libertés
et à aucun moment il n'a vraiment fait
ce travail de pédagogie comme on l'a vu
en espagne par exemple où chaque
personne est appelé pour prendre un
rendez vous ou alors aucune réflexion
n'a été fait non plus sur les ruptures
du système de santé
non il revient encore et toujours à son
jouet préféré à savoir la répression les
amendes ou encore l'intimidation
alors même que l'om est il faut le
rappeler n'est pas du tout favorable à
une obligation de la vaccination lui s'y
prête et je crois que ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'on passe à côté du constat que
l'on devrait faire ce qu'il y à un aveu
de la défiance politique aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est la méthode qu'il faut
critiquer il parlait de transparence
vous l'avais dit dans votre reportage
mais où est la transparence des lobbys
aujourd'hui elle est toujours absente
il faudrait aussi qu'on parle encore du
la levée des brevets puisque puisque
nous avons une crise mondiale nous
savons qu'il ne pourra y avoir qu'une
réponse mondiale
or la levée des brevets qui justement
est la meilleure réponse à ça eh bien il
l'est toujours
c'est toujours pas à l'ordre du jour or
on sait très bien que même si on vaccine
les soignants et même si on vaccine
l'ensemble de la population ni ne sommes
pas à l'abri de variants venus d'autres
pays qui n'ont pas eu la même
vaccination et ça aussi ce quart à ce
sujet qu'il n'a pas abordé juste juste
quand même pour dire ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que mettre en avant
l'intérêt général
quand on se pose la question de jouer
encore la levée de brevets ou sont
encore les grands
ce this man des hôpitaux où sont les
excuses pour les mensonges mettre en
avant l'intérêt général quand derrière
c'est la manipulation et des mensonges
ça fait vraiment mal quand même
on va écouter une députée européenne
europe ecologie les verts michèle rivasi
écouter ce qu'elle a twitté hier c'est
l'apartheid dans le pays des droits de
l'homme
alors depuis 1 michèle rivasi a retiré
sa publication pour présenter ses
excuses pour l'emploi de ce mot jugé
maladroit il se dit pourtant indignés
par les propos d' emmanuel macron
clairement il ya une ligne rouge qui a
été franchi julien ou 12 aujourd'hui qui
provoque par la même occasion une vraie
fracture une vraie scission entre les
français oui je le pense
les annonces d'hier sont extrêmement
inquiétantes
elles sont extrêmement inquiétantes pour
autant moi je ne cautionne pas et je
dénonce tous les discours excessif que
l'on a pu entendre de certains excités
de certains fous furieux qui font des
comparaisons qui sont totalement
scandaleuse moi je m'en tiens à ce qui a
été dit je m'en tiens au recul des
libertés individuelles ce qui est grave
ce qui est gravissime
je m'en tiens aussi au reniement de la
parole présidentielle de la parole
publique qui n'a plus aucune valeur
tous les ministres d'ailleurs vous
l'avez très bien montré dans votre
reportage
tous les ministres tous les députés de
la majorité le président de la
république lui-même avait bien dit qu'il
n'y aurait pas de vaccination
obligatoire il ya encore quelques
semaines que le pass à lithaire ne
serait pas imposé pour elle dans un café
un cinéma ou un restaurant donc la
parole publique aujourd'hui n'a plus
aucune valeur ce qui est extrêmement
grave et ce qui peut aussi expliquer les
chiffres de l'abstention aux dernières
élections départementales et régionales
parce qu'il ya une déconnexion totale
les gens n'y croient plus les gens n'y
croient plus voit bien que nous avons
des pantins qui disent tout et n'importe
quoi qui se renie au bout de quelques
semaines et ça c'est extrêmement grave
ce qui est très grave aussi c'est sur la
mise en pratique
parce que là nous avons eu les annonces
ensuite on a eu je dirais le
les petits catalogues de monsieur attal
la de monsieur v rang avec les
adaptations en fonction des publics est
donc là on vient de comprendre et de
découvrir que les mineurs dont 12 à 17
ans allait avoir donc le passé ni terre
à partir du 30 août
et puis les différentes catégories c'est
à dire que les restaurateurs les
cafetiers qu'on ait déjà été durement
éprouvée qui ont fait des efforts inouïs
pharaonique depuis un an et demi vont
devoir devenir des vigiles des policiers
vont devoir contrôler vont devoir donc
pour un café avec les risques évidemment
que l'on connaît d'une société qui se
fracture de plus en plus une société de
plus en plus violente
on a vu malheureusement ce qui s'est
passé en seine-et-marne avec le pauvre
petit théo donc qui a été assistant
assassiné pour une facture de 93 euros
qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans cette
société là s'il ya des conflits aux
abords des restaurants des cafés ou des
lieux publics pour ce genre de choses
donc clairement et peu les personnels
soignants aussi percer les soignants qui
étaient les héros de la république il ya
encore un an qui ont du temps avec des
efforts considérables qui ont dû
fabriquer des surblouse il faut le
rappeler avec des sacs poubelles quand
même les soignants de la sixième
puissance du monde et ses soignants
aujourd'hui sont désignés comme les
boucs émissaires et pratiquement comme
les propagateurs du virus non clairement
il faut laisser il fallait laisser la
liberté à ses fins et les soignants qui
sont responsables qu'ils sont adultes et
qu'ils savent très bien ce qu'il faut
faire pour protéger les restaurateurs
ont demandé le report d'application du
passani terre prévu début août ça a été
refusé
julien houle viens de parler d'aidé
soignant qui seront désormais contraints
faute d'être sanctionnés et pas payé il
ya la question des enfants aussi qui
peut choquer beaucoup de parents et
entraîné beaucoup de crispation parce
que on a compris qu'on aurait une
campagne de vaccination dans les
collèges ça veut dire quoi qu on doit
craindre que certains enfants soient
exclus de certaines activités
périscolaires ou de certains cours de
sport par exemple à la rentrée c'est
quand même pas pareil de vacciner un
enfant de 12 ans et un adulte vous en
conviendrez
on nous annonçait déjà une campagne de
déscolarisation quand les écoles ont été
réouvertes je rappelle que la france est
le pays développé qui a
laissez le plus longtemps ou vers les
écoles et on nous disait que des parents
ne voudrais pas placer leurs enfants on
n'a pas eu de vague de déscolarisation
et les parents qui font garder leurs
enfants à l'école ne sont pas scolarisés
se se comptent vraiment en quelques
poignées je pense que ce sera la même
chose sur la vaccination ou de toute
façon il ya déjà vaccinées ce conflit
soit scolarisée que sur ce coup ci le
rassemblement national et la france
mais quelle garantie vous tout
simplement en tant que maire qu'est ce
que vous allez dire à vos administrés
quand des parents vous diront mais
quelles garanties at on pour des enfants
qui n'ont même pas fini leur croissance
par rapport à un vaccin qui qui a mis
voilà assez rapidement qui a été fait
rapidement les enfants c'est pas pareil
que les adultes
et ça il ya beaucoup de parents qui le
pensent qu est ce qu on vous leur
répondre et vous tout simplement en tant
que maire moi je suis papa médecin je
suis pas à l'om est ce jeu vous
l'académie de médecine un certain nombre
d'autres pays aussi vacciner les enfants
à partir de 12 ans donc j'ai envie de
dire que s'il ya des autorités
sanitaires c'est aussi pour qu'elles
fassent leur travail et je voudrais me
porté en faux par rapport à ce que dit
la france a soumises
il ya eu la france a donné énormément de
vaccins un certain nombre de pays en
voie de développement alors les brevets
ont peut-être pas été levées mais tous
les brevets sont pas français mais où
des livraisons importantes j'étais
encore tout à l'heure avec les des
autorités du burkina faso avec qui nous
faisons de la coopération décentralisée
qui ont été livrées massivement en
vaccins depuis la france y ait eu un
plan pour l'hôpital qui peut-être pas
suffisant on peut toujours le dire mais
avec une annulation tête avec du
matériel flambant neuf allez dans les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui il ya encore une
négociation pour une deuxième vague
d'investissements mais énormément de
matériel a été a été achetée et une
partie de la dette a été apathique
donc c'est simple de raconter un peu
n'importe quoi mais en tout cas oui il
ya eu et ce 10 juillet au 12 n'est pas
faux il y a eu une parole politique qui
a changé effectivement et moi je prends
ça plus comme une forme d'humilité que
d'arrogance les les la situation a
évolué défavorablement avec
une variante on n'attendait pas avec une
ralentissement la population est
vaccinée même si aujourd'hui plus de 55
% de la population est actionné 0% sous
douze ans entre environ 50 et 18 ans ça
veut dire que dans la population majeure
il y a énormément une très très grande
majorité personnes qui sont vaccinées et
qui donc font confiance à ce vaccin
on va laisser répondre julie garnier
mais avant cela quelques petites
précisions ce soir apparemment encore
des évolutions puisque olivier verront
vient d'annoncer que le pass sanitaire
12 17 ans s'appliquera à compter du 30
août un finalement et pas début août et
que le schéma de vaccination sera
considérée en france comme complet une
semaine seulement après la seconde dose
1 plutôt que deux actuellement on voit
quelques petites modifications
julie garnier ça montre quoi une
certaine ouverture d'esprit du
gouvernement qui écoute les français en
colère je crois que ça démontre surtout
que les décisions seront prises
on va dire à l'aveuglé malheureusement
il faut quand même rappeler la façon
dont a été fait cette annonce c'est à
dire qu'elle a été faite de manière
solitaire encore une fois il n'y a pas
eu de conseil des ministres il n'y a pas
eu encore de débats au parlement nous
avons tous été devant notre télévision à
apprendre voilà ce qui allait se passer
et le service après-vente des jours
d'après allez un petit peu étayé les
yeux nous ou revenir sur certaines
dispositions
c'est comme ça chaque fois c'est comme
ça depuis le début de la crise et
honnêtement ça en devient lassant ou a
minima mais en tout cas énervant pour
pour d'autres et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
ce dont on a besoin c'est justement
comme l'avait dire le gouvernement ni à
croire que les paroles ne coûtent pas
cher c'est de transparence et de
démocratie et participation or voilà
c'est tout l'inversé à chaque fois qu'il
se passe c'est toujours des décisions
qui sont unilatérales et qui sont
contraignantes toujours avec les mêmes
et jamais avec les autres et je redis
mais toujours annoncé aujourd'hui que
les profiteurs de crise sont toujours
astreints du moindre effort c'est tout
bonnement insupportable
alors que on a besoin d'un plan massif
dans les hôpitaux alors qu'on a besoin
d'un plan massif dans les services
publics alors qu'on a besoin d'un plan
massif dans l'éducation et dans les
écoles qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est que
aujourd'hui alors que huit français sont
dix sur dix sont pour une taxation des
profits et bien
gouvernement se refuse toujours à mettre
à contribution ceux qui se sont enrichis
pendant la crise pas seulement d'en
préserver leur patrimoine et se sont
même enrichi les 500 familles les plus
riches ont vu leur fortune progressé de
30% cette année 30% ayant quatre ans ça
a presque doublé
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour mettre à
contribution justement l'ensemble du
pays et arrêter de faire porter la crise
uniquement sur les épaules des
travailleurs et toujours les mêmes
16e peu ça aussi qui est qui est agaçant
à la longue merci en tout cas tous les
trois à vincent chauvet julien en 12
julie garnier d'avoir été avec nous nous
avoir apporté vos opinions respectives
merci à vous